c'est pas très disciplinés mais c'est ma
façon à moi je crois de d'aborder le les
tournages je viens que même si je suis
pas très bien je ferai un effort pour
avoir l'air très détendu mais de toute
façon je sais bien que je suis habitué à
faire beaucoup de chutes très nerveuse
et ça étonne beaucoup de gens qui ne me
connaissent pas justement parce que je
sais que j'ai toujours l'air assez calme
donc je sais que par nature je fais
souvent beaucoup d'efforts pour moi même
beaucoup géré pour lutter contre une
nature que je sais trop envahissant des
qui ne me plaît pas toujours voyez qui
est lourde à porter donc le tournage
c'est pareil je fais souvent des efforts
pour avoir l'air plus détendu plus gai
que je ne le suis plus la concentration
je trouve ça presque impudique vous
voyez d'en parler parce que je trouve
que les acteurs j'ai bien ceux comme
c'est des choses qu'on doive faible dont
on ne parle pas je crois que ça c'est
puritaine non je trouve ça vous et vous
voyez c'est comme les danseurs qui par
leur aide ou d'un coût de l'effort
physique j'ai hâte qu'ils font je veux
dire je vis dans le propos n'est pas là
je veux dire on parle d'autre chose on
ça c'est vrai mais tout tout coûte je
vais d assez peu importe ce que l'on
fait ce jeudi il faut le faire ce qui
est important c'est de le faire bientôt
ya comme on a envie de le faire mais pas
par les deux prévenus comme combien ça
vous a coûté s'annonce pas très
intéressant d'ailleurs c'est une
habitude de parler de la concentration
des acteurs que je me concentre pas
beaucoup ça c'est moi enfin tous les cas
d'une façon très strict
[Musique]